it took a couple of years but as soon as
I gotten knocked off of product and
started shifting to people the whole
world opened up and if you can do
everything in your business and you can
do it yourself then your mission isn't
big enough if my people go my god the
company goes people are your company
rise and shine it's an spresso time good
morning believe nation it's Evan my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have an amazing gift inside
you that I want to see exploded on to
the world
so grab your coffee and sip on today's
message focus on the people over to you
Will Smith I've always been really
product oriented you know it's like I
want to win when I do something I want
to win I wanted to be number one and I
want to smash it and I had a period I
have a daughter and I was over 15 year
old daughter and she really she got me
and shifted my focus from product to
people it took a couple of years but as
soon as I gotten knocked off of product
and started shifting to people the whole
world opened up for me again and acting
opened up in a whole new way to not go
into day one of a movie trying to figure
out what everybody has to do so we win
versus opening up and every person's a
new it's a whole new world meaning the
character you play all the people you
work with both absolutely you know
generally when I went into a product
when I went into a meeting with a
director my focus was can this guy win
can this girl win and that it was a it
was a you know a pathology that got
broken for me a couple of years ago and
then releasing that and just wanting to
connect with people and wanting to grow
and wanted to get new ideas and have new
experiences that don't have to have
an outcome it just opened up a whole new
world for me and I fell in love and then
I couldn't imagine what else I could do
in acting that could add so much to my
life other than acting if you want to go
fast you go alone if you want to go far
you go with the team I think this is
something that really holds a lot of
entrepreneurs back is they think they
can do everything themselves and if you
can do everything in your business and
you can do it yourself then your mission
isn't big enough you're letting yourself
down you were capable of so much more
than what you're currently doing because
you are unwilling to bring on a team you
have Michael Jordan level talent at
something but chances are you only
spending five to ten percent of your day
every day actually doing the thing that
you are world-class at and the other
ninety to ninety-five percent of the
time you're spent doing all the other
stuff around your business that maybe
you're good at but it's not what you
have Michael Jordan level talent but you
were born to do and so you need to
expand your team you need to bring
people on to help you I look at this
YouTube channel as an example in my
early days I was doing everything myself
and I think that's good thing I think at
the beginning you need to do everything
yourself I hate spending money on things
before I'm making money I was doing
everything myself I was in front of the
camera I was behind the camera I was
editing I was researching I was doing
everything thumbnails titles tags
everything and I made one video a week
that was my max output with everything
else that I was doing was making one
video a week and then as I brought on
people to help me as my business started
to grow I was starting to make a little
bit of money I put that right back into
my company and I hired a team and I
started with one person and then it
expanded to two and three and four that
was eight of us now who work on this
YouTube channel and by bringing on a
team I'm able to just go so much further
I get to spend my time doing the work
that I love I get to send my time in
front of the camera I get to certain
height I'm still reviewing all the
videos that go up but get the cement I'm
hiring and coaching my team and they
take care of everything else and that's
allowed me to go from one video a week
to three videos a day I'm able to have a
much greater impact on you guys on my
mission I'm able to create a lot more
content that I am proud of because I'm
not spending only five to ten percent of
my time doing the thing that
love to do so like I said in the
beginning I think you should do
everything yourself find a way to make
any kind of money possible and then
invest that back and when you bring the
people on your team understand that
doesn't have to cost a lot of money or
anything at the beginning in the early
days of my business
I had interns work for me I had free
interns come from high schools to get
credit for their course I had
international students come for credits
so that they can go back home and say
that they worked in Canada I had people
working part time for me one two three
hours a day so that they could take some
of the things off my plate you don't
have to go and drop 50k on somebody to
be able to build your business you can
use a lot of the labor and the friends
and the community that you have around
you to help you get started I like start
in the beginning everything by myself
just to understand how things work to
understand what I have talents and
abilities and a real deep passion
interest in and the things I don't
quickly offload them to people who love
doing those things attracting the right
teammates for free at the beginning
paying a little bit as you go and then
as you start making more money as
they're contributing more back to you
right as I brought on my team I can go
to one video a day and then to a day and
a three day that allows me to have a
bigger impact that I was gonna make more
money to then bring that and invest it
back in the channel to make even better
videos but you see what's coming I got
some such a surprises and so pumped and
excited by it and it all starts with
that mindset that you can go fast by
yourself or you can go far as a team and
I know a lot of people get burned I know
a lot of people make mistakes in their
first hire a lot of people bring on
somebody whether it's paid or whether
it's an internship and it doesn't work
out and you spend a lot of time training
them and it doesn't work out and a lot
of people didn't retreat back and they
say well I didn't work out I'm never
hiring anybody again I could just do it
myself I know it's gonna work out and as
long as you adopt that mindset you're
gonna stay small chances are the reason
why that first thing didn't work out
that first tyre is because you suck at
hiring and you suck at managing and
that's okay because at the beginning you
suck at everything whatever you're doing
in your business the first time you try
that you sucked at it so don't expect to
be great at hiring the first person that
comes in don't expect to be great at
managing somebody the first time you try
you're gonna make mistakes you look at
any successful company look at their
foundation very very very rarely
the first employee for that company
still around a year later two years
later ten years later 20 years later
they don't stick around because the
entrepreneurs they messed up and so
that's part of the journey you will mess
up you will make bad hires we will suck
at managing and as you get more
experience and as you learn and as you
get better yourself you will develop the
skills to be able to do it and it's
important because your mission is big
and you cannot do this alone now I've
got some special bonus clips for you but
before that my question the day is I'm
curious what is the next thing in your
business that you are going to hand off
to somebody else to really accelerate
your growth so you can focus on what you
have Michael Jordan level talent at what
is that thing you're gonna delegate away
leave it down the comments below I
really want to hear from you thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love enjoy the bonus clip and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events presto
[Music]
when I worked for other companies some
of them not mentioning names were so bad
they would treat people the old way I'm
the boss here's what you're gonna do
because I'm the boss right or there were
times for example when maybe had a
dollar for lunch II can't get a lot for
a dollar so I just knew that that's how
I was and if I had a company that I had
a control of my gosh everyone's gonna be
treated the way I wanted to be treated
so the minute we could afford it
everyone had free lunch whether they had
money or not you have free lunch we pay
for it for you car pool we'll pay for
that so we started doing things for
people that I wish happened to me maybe
that's part of fate maybe because a lot
of things along the way weren't so good
that as things started getting good it
was so easy for me to share with our
people so easy to do that people
sometimes don't save money as soon as we
possibly could afford it we started
profit sharing where at the end of every
year and we'll take that profit sharing
and put in a retirement fund for you
it's yours it's yours if your so many
years it goes with you no matter where
you go but it sure is it's your money
that's really incredible and how much do
you think that that sort of Golden Rule
approach has fed into your ridiculously
low turnover rate which is literally
almost unprecedented I mean that's crazy
I try and treat people exactly the way
they'd want to be treated exactly the
way I would have wanted to be treated
I'm happy with my people I realized my
people aren't the company if my people
go my god the company goes people are
your company and they take care of the
customer the customer is always right no
matter what so what do we do so the
customers happier if somebody's unhappy
we would try and discover why and
because you treat people this way and
we'd love them you walk in our company
it's love if you go to the front desk
here in Century City this girl just has
the biggest smile say hi welcome to John
Paul Mitchell Systems she loves what she
does our big problem is we don't have
turnover we have so many people want to
work for us and the thing is you gotta
wait for somebody to die now as we grow
we'll add one or two on obviously at a
time sure and we're pretty big now
because we're in 96 countries it's how
you take care of people anywhere in the
world you don't boss them around you
includable what you're doing the key to
I think being a good business leader is
is your is how good you are with people
I think if you can care genuinely care
about people not just your fellow
directors but you know the cleaning lady
the switchboard operator
you know everybody throughout the
company you know if you praise and don't
criticize you know people people will
flourish and so I think you know it's
really your people's skills that will
set you set you apart and and I don't
think that can be over over emphasized I
think that just you just got to you know
if I get if I'm on a virgin plane I will
make sure that I always have a notebook
in my back back pocket you know make
sure I get out and talk to all the staff
you know if they've got issues you know
make sure I don't just you know hear the
issue are not write it down make sure
those those issues get written down you
know talk to the passengers if they've
got issues make sure those issues get
written down who in this audience
believes without a shred of doubt that
nothing not technology not IP not
patents not trademarks not brands not
relationships not any asset of a game
company is worth more than to our
company's success than the quality of
our teams if you believe ever that I've
said that regimen okay a lot of hands
that's awesome now raise your hand if
that sounds idealistic you believe it in
your heart we want to believe it but
your mind is just kind of full of
questions those other things are pretty
important okay good we're pretty sure of
this which is great now lastly raise
your hand if your company your
shareholders your boardrooms all believe
this and internalize it the same way you
do without a shred of doubt okay a lot
less hands now you know this is where I
think we have a problem as an industry
because until we all agree until all
stakeholders fully believe in the value
of our people than we struggle to
prioritize what really matters and it's
gonna hold us back as an industry from
you know our our full potential this
volume you you have the most important
work ever if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple that would be like a
little beacon hey believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details